les deux boîtes noires placé à l'arrière
et à l'avant du boeing d'air india ont
été remontés à la surface au large des
côtes de l'irlande avant de prendre
connaissance des révélations qu'elles
vont apporter sur les conditions exactes
de la catastrophe
le fait de les avoir retrouvés par près
de 2000 mètres de fond constitue déjà un
exploit technique particulièrement
remarquable philippe dumez
le navire canadien qui a participé avec
un navire français aux recherches des
boîtes noires du boeing d'air india est
déjà rentré au port de cork en irlande à
son bord le jumeau du sous marin
téléguidé qui a permis de retrouver les
deux boîtes d'enregistrement de tous les
évènements du vol et ceci grâce au son
des balises qui fonctionnait poopy cette
opération qui s'est bien déroulée a tout
de même nécessité de descendre le sous
marin aux limites de ses possibilités
c'est à dire à 2000 mètres sous l'eau
ensuite il a fallu couvrir une
superficie de plusieurs kilomètres
carrés
la position de la chute de l'avion
n'étant pas connu avec précision
enfin il a fallu agripper les boîtes
avec un système qui n'était pas bien
adaptés mais heureusement celle-ci avait
été éjecté de l'avion et se trouvaient
sur un terrain plat le sous-marin scarab
a également permis de prendre des images
qui seront bien utiles aux enquêteurs
le navire câblier léon thévenin rentrer
maintenant vers l'irlande après ce que
les spécialistes estiment être un
véritable exploit à son bord les deux
boîtes noires équivalente à celle ci et
qui permettront après étude des
enregistrements de savoir pourquoi
l'avion d'air india s'est abîmé en mer
en moins de 30 secondes
le 23 juin dernier